I think that the word that people are
really focused on is the word love and I
don't wanna have like a full platonic
discussion about it but what do you mean
when you say the president doesn't love
America what does that mean to you well
actually if I could express it more
clearly what I mean is he doesn't
express it it did say does the president
does it does not love anything or anyone
i don't know i don't not a psychiatrist
and he doesn't have one and he doesn't
need one so I don't know where see
what's not is not that he doesn't hurt
yourself express it yeah so you're what
you're saying is when you listen to him
the words you hear make you think that
he doesn't express a way that would give
you the confidence that he loves America
but you got it but you don't doubt but
you don't doubt that he loves America
right if you want to put it that way I
don't doubt that he loves America in the
sense that he's a patriot he believes in
the Constitution he's going to follow
the laws of the United States I just
don't know how far I don't know i don't
know that i don't know that agree really
loves America I could be persuaded if he
would talk like that but from the way he
talks it sounds to me like a guy who has
trouble expressing love for America